I'm and now I will sing a wandering
minstrel I will come hey what's going on
everybody for first leafy's I'm Sean
Evans you're watching hot one it's the
show without a question and even hotter
wings and today I'm joined by comedian
Nick Kroll you know I'm from Kroll show
and the lead is hit Broadway show
oh hello is coming to Netflix this month
and you can catch him in Captain
Underpants which is in theaters now Nick
welcome to the show thank you for having
so you guys have your own one no hot one
yep hot wine no product placement isn't
ethically how how do how are you on that
I'm good on it I'm not especially I'm a
little concerned that all of a sudden
you guys are sliding your own hot sauce
into the mixer yeah be a separation of
church and state this whole show is just
basically so we can get celebrity to
give de facto endorsement for our sauce
no to scale out of business that way hey
I'm Nicole I'm on hot ones and this
sauce hot one sauce can suck a dick
[Music]
all right so this first one is sriracha
sriracha is no big deal it's not but I
do like that you guys these are cold so
this is my first touch going this is a
cold wing so that's how we're certain is
that it's hot ones have a cold one on ha
one I don't want to start by taking it
back to your time at the mountain school
cook room because from what I understand
it's this sort of teenager hippie
commune in the middle of nowhere Vermont
yes uh what was that like that was like
the best experience of my life you live
on a farm in yeah in the rural Vermont
like 45 kids and you run around and uh
hike and have solos and feed cows and
muck [ __ ] there's a lot of mucking of
[ __ ] I find I'm I was out last night
first of all I'm hungover second of all
this is like they hang out ya know I was
thinking about that I was like oh this
is going to be fun this is like this
like a Saturday it's like going to Old
Town Tavern I'm in a connection wings in
a diet coke please I really Joe Bosco's
kind of been left in the dust about goes
like that first hot sauce in the game
something you're like huh it's like
Jamiroquai I appreciate you man you did
some important work for me but end of
the day you know when you're outcast I
want to talk about your time at the
league yes for a lot of fan untouchable
of all the guest spots that you had huh
which athlete was the best comedic actor
um
Terrell Suggs was very funny JJ Watt is
unbelievably talented Chad Ochocinco had
four phones on him we were in Vegas with
him and he he started tweeting pictures
of himself and it's the jamás at the
slots at like 4:00 a.m. and I was like
this is a lonely man is it true that you
slept through your alarm clock on the
first day of filming
I'm always good on the first day of
filming it's the second day you get
cocky you're like I did it I got to work
on time I did my job
and then the second day you wake up
panicked too like a text being like hey
just checking on where you are you're
like
right now I am dead asleep 45 minutes
away from where I'm supposed to be and
if you look in the pilot there's AG one
day we're like Ruxin's got Bed Head and
it's not it was not a character choice
it was like I literally slept through
the first the first scene this is bull
semen yes
squeezed up this morning so your friend
Aziz Ansari it come this food pop
culture guru which I imagine him I say
he's just become an icon but especially
in this food space which is important to
you
because I bet that there's some fringe
benefit they're gonna go to eating buddy
of Aziz yeah Aziz has turned me on to a
ton of good food over the years so he is
very particular about what he will eat
him and that but he is her Manickam
killer food or there's my first weird
spit just came out out of nowhere
normally that only happens when you yawn
and talk at the same time not hot one no
no that was like a true weird release of
fluid from me that I was not in control
of it all I'm trying to think what was
the last meal I had with him I was at
his house and he made brick oven pizza
he's got like a cool brick up and then
he knows how to make like proper
Neapolitan pizza it's delicious but I'm
like bro ovens [ __ ] hot enough let's
go I'm not tasting the coffee I am
tasting that wolf though I want to talk
to you about oh hello
great because like our show yes it kind
of puts its celebrity guests into this
uncomfortable interview yeah Matt but
instead of making people eat hot wings
we make them eat too much tuna fish and
we load that tuna in in the earlier in
the afternoon so I understand your food
prep thing here guys a logistical
challenge a logistical challenge about
like when you get those wings the
difference being maybe your wings are
cold when someone eats it in our case
it's a huge tuna sandwich that's been
sitting on to the lights on a Broadway
stage for hours before the show waiting
to be dropped down on approval
platter with little wings on the side do
you get some sort of sadistic pleasure
out of unleashing Gil and George on
these celebrity guests in your famous
friend yes yeah yes they do because when
you're doing it through a character it
so you can get away with anything it
happens also that John is like the
fastest funniest person on the planet
and so he's doing a lot of dancing and
I'm both of us can sort of pop in and
just give some shot that in the kidney I
just had a weird wing burr it's got the
sweet upfront there's a little sweet on
the front mm-hmm the word hot one sauce
a lot of lovin care women up the next
part of our show is recurring segments
we have called explain that Graham and
what we do is we do a deep dive and our
guests Instagram we call interesting
pictures that need more contact right so
I'll show you the picture and then you
just tell me the bigger story I'm bummed
that I'm not the picture I was going to
post on my way up here of a old man into
a biking outfit on a bike with a
cigarette in his mouth I hadn't gotten
that up on the ground by the time I
could explain it which I guess I just
did so there we go
is this from a high school yearbook or
where that's from ruff camp that's from
another one of the privileged things
that I did in my life but truly more
than anything it's the quote which is
get serious Nikki and I feel like I'm
reading that quote to myself every day
what do you remember about your high
school basketball days playing point
guard I was a solid 7th grade point
guard in my Jewish day school peak kind
of early peaked in eighth grade
athletically peaked in eighth grade for
sure so I get to high school and maybe
five five one but I understood the game
really you know what I mean you
distributed the ball I have good court
sense I had good good awareness not a
great shooter you don't have to be a
point guard and you do now that's the
bummer Steph Curry [ __ ] everything out
Oh me and Joan Rivers on a plane on a
plane together that was before she died
okay cool this was this is not a picture
from after Joan Rivers died this was one
of the best fights I ever had I'm going
to name drop a few times love it I saw
Bradley Cooper a dear friend
we go to the bookstore he bought me a
neck pillow sweet then we get on the
plane and I'm seated next to Joan Rivers
who I know a little bit
she was so fast because she's dead now
yeah no longer alive and so if you see
again if you see Joan Rivers on a plane
someone has put her there she is not
alive anymore she is dead all the flight
attendants knew her she had brought them
gifts she really liked love these people
and they loved her we said we're about
to take off you know putting your
seatbelt on she goes bless just looking
at Bradley Kirk she goes this plane is
going to crash and the headline is going
to read Bradley Cooper and two comedians
died today
oh yeah just for me how many of these do
you do a week if we back load them
uh-huh then I'll have like easier weeks
but then if our bank like our reserve
runs dry then you'll have to start
stacking them so I've done as many as
three in a week before do you a lot of
wings rest would know like it's ruined
wings from ya know what I mean I you
know and two it's like probably get this
challenge is like sometimes I'm like oh
does anybody want to work with me when
it's not wings you know what I mean of
course it's like you know like would
never call be like what about a travel
series where you're going the best ways
in America are like like I'm done with
the words this is yeah I've been
typecast as like the wing guy I know
I've been taught cast as the like
handsome romantic and eat must be tough
it's tough it's tough to be treated like
an object I'll play that much
I'm sorry see your dad worked what the
New York Times called a private CIA and
was even chosen by the kwaity government
to track down Saddam Hussein's hidden
assets yes and I wonder what it must be
like to be in high school trying to hide
weed from one of the most prominent
private investigators in the world
um shout-out to Jules Kroll
I wouldn't call the private CIA I mean
the New York Times might have called it
that but I'm a more reputable
journalistic institution Cher
at one time I got caught some girl
ratted me out I got a party and some
girl like told her mom about the party
who my dad like woke me up the next
morning and then like very quickly and
succinctly interrogated me where I had
no choice but to be very honest with him
very quickly was just it was such a
shock he did some crazy stuff but the
truth is my mom was really the one who
knew what was going on hmm and this is
gluten-free yeah it's good and Franco
[Music]
the zombies brains are out is that how
it works
I thought somebody's wanted to eat
brains well a zombie is just dead so if
you were to die in some sort of
situation we had your skull split open
but if you would just have exposed brain
sure a little bit not well whatever I'm
just wondering if like a Dom be like if
they eat brains like they just start to
eat their own brains like slowly slowly
get in there so for my money Kroll show
is one of the best character showcases
that's ever been on Comedy Central and
that's really saying something so what I
want to do is ask you some food
questions but there's a little bit of a
twist
now that the zombie apocalypse I'm
soaking in yeah I'd like you to channel
some of those glassing personalities oh
that's if you try to answer you know
good question for Bobby bottleservice
yeah what are the do's and don't do it
when it comes to ordering off of VIP
menu Bobby would be so psyched to be on
the show Jack raw [ __ ] jiggly shot
yeah Bobby's VIP and Reuters very much
VIP adverse languages he wants to Aspen
what is done dodge there we go the
research was done gone is it's all
chicken wings but it's all sous-vide
because like honestly who has the time
to bite through bone you just want to be
able to like we're sending an intern to
get coffees what does Lizzy one I'm
doing can I do a sriracha smoothie
please just water help or not I'm sure
you've done the studies and this is
again what about bull semen it's bull
semen that does that bull semen is the
leading reliever of hot sauce pace wow
it's very interesting
because you start to get cocky I was
like this shows not so [ __ ] hard mmm
you watch everybody do the show mm-hmm
and you decide whether they're trying to
play it cool or they're leaning into the
heat and you're like could I ignore it
if I wanted to what are you feeling now
now that you're actually experiencing it
I guess it medically would be described
as mouth gonorrhea dabomb beyond
insanity this is like oh it is and it's
literally a bomb it's not literally a
bomb I know this is a bomb it is here we
are in the time-life building I'm
strapped with a bomb I want this on
camera we all clear on this guys okay
mm-hmm do people send you also trying to
get on the show now crazy
dude you must be [ __ ] swimmin ha ha ha
ha yeah bro good job dad I guess there
it's the back of the throat that catches
you and now I will sing a wandering
minstrel I will come oh right I'm ready
to shoot my my parents death see now
just miss him every day I don't know why
I pushed him off that bridge it's just
missed them
that's a sleeper veal tears right there
be careful with the napkins you know
your hands the sauce is based as eyes
Wow
this is older and now I have a straight
up head of that sauce oh my
right straight up now that's all smiles
[Music]
computer people have done that before
right yeah you're not the first one to
go down this road oh well
whoo there's a buzz now this is the buzz
the people part about that train up I
have a go vibrating on the side of my
head yeah yeah the normal normal no need
to panic we've had the distinction of
playing a pig and sing in an actual
douche and that Seth Rogen movie sausage
party yeah from the outside looking in
voice acting looks like the cushiest gig
in Hollywood but I know that there's
something about it that has to suck what
do people not know about the plight of a
voice actor that you eventually go on a
show to promote it on the side of your
face starts to vibrate Wow I keep
getting you're doing handy why Brandon
another non-absorbent napkin great wow I
feel like I'm straight up trippin is it
like actual acting do you get into a
headspace or just get into the booth and
start talking I do I do the work you
know what I mean I do the work when I'm
voice acting I get out there I do my
best if you don't work I take the time
commit
okay well this is crazy this is more
than this is you can't imagine it right
I've never my face has never vibrated
like this before am i wearing a Hawaiian
shirt it's like getting married yeah so
you having some cold feet up yeah all
right just for the rest of my life
[Music]
no one's ever rectally eaten the wings
yes person never do it should we but
chug some Mad Dogs is a friend ah yeah
that's some rich dick [ __ ] right there's
like honestly I don't even taste hot
sauce anymore I need to soak a tampon in
Mad Dog 357 and then but chug it I don't
want to eat the other half of it but I
feel like I also don't want to not do my
best
you commit you can get full you know
[Music]
reven sighs so in 2007 you moved to LA
and you did with a lot of aspiring
actors and comedians do where you moved
into the Oakwood apartment yeah what was
that living experience like because that
place has this sort of notorious
reputation as being this sort of island
of misfit toys like Hollywood's version
of a roach motel
well like Mad Dog 357 the Oakwood sneaks
up on you and it's only a few minutes
later that you realize that you've done
something terrible to your body
there's like a little store and the
store is covered in children's head
shots like brooding six-year-old boys
like that it is one of the sadder places
in the world who you magic does stink up
I guess I am lactose intolerant and
you're risking it all we does Bulls come
have lactose in it I think it's a good
bet I was a wish you were on highway 7
Elm
I wish I had that line mm-hmm besides
bridge something that someone can say to
you I'm lactose yeah and if I said do
yeah yeah that would've been great that
would been great but you know I missed
opportunity missed opportunity for you
for me
homerun GU shake it up
all right so this is Blair's Megadeath
sauce I just want to add some motion
with lipid resist
maybe if I think I'm going to throw up
I'll think about the hot sauce left
all right nakedness tradition around
here to dab the left-wing jab we're
going to dab dab it up you don't have to
if you don't want to we're gonna dab oh
that's a cool thing to do right now oh
yeah that's that look you look very cool
right now that's funny I've never dab
before look at I'm Nick come on Finn and
dab I do it like that like it's just a
little bit of something too much here we
go I put more on here than you did I'm a
little concerned with it you're not a
fake you wanna do you want to switch
wings we could do that looks like a
princess bride moment mm-hmm I know that
you want to switch chicken wings with me
wait what is how does well Shawn do it
is it inconceivable you can he was in
the back of the throat it's driving me
crazy that I can't nail the accent so
I'm bailing on the bed I think that you
did nail the accent and you know what's
amazing to me Nick Earl you're not the
second guest really to do that
impression who was it Jordan Peele okay
what happened we're hoping is
inconceivable Oh [ __ ] yeah great minds
great minds the Jordan people might have
the best mind right ears neck Cheers
the Jordan Peele
I'm gonna get this whole [ __ ] room
zip oh I have my yearly physical right
after this I think that some of your
vitals are going to be spiking yeah we
got your test results back mr. Kroll you
havin a tremendous amount of bull semen
running through your system but to the
kids out there I just want you to know
we've said a lot of things today we've
joined a center I'm not going to endorse
marijuana
I'm not going to endorse alcohol abuse
and I'm for sure not going to tell you
to go get a tampon soak it in the
hottest hot sauce you can find and stick
it up your butt and then walk around all
day very principled stand it's brave of
you Nick so don't do that we did it well
you know what you are officially as a
champion Nick Kroll because you've
worked your way through the wings you
know a little nervous to start it out
but settled right in and got on top
every single one of these is this not
can you see this knot on my nose or cuz
I just feel it we've film in 4k great
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life hi I'm Nick Kroll you can
see me uh in oh hello on Broadway on
Netflix John Mulaney I'm in the house at
the end of the month Will Ferrell
Amy Poehler Jason Mantzoukas amazing
cast of people Captain Underpants
I played professor poopy pants uh whoo
my ear just popped
how much money will you give me to stick
this dab of death sauce napkin in my eye
I'll give you a hundred seventy-five
bucks one eighty hey what's going on hot
ones fans if you liked the video maybe
meet us halfway throw us a subscribe if
you didn't like the video don't
subscribe I don't want you I don't want
you in the tent but if you like the
video subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you
more than a friend